if you have chronic inflammation or pain
in your body
this video can be very useful to you uh
inflammation is a huge problem and
unfortunately the way that people
fix it is they just camouflage it with
medications and what that does is it
just continues the problem longer and
longer so today i'm going to get to the
underlying root causes
when people are given the wrong
diagnosis
it's like you can really make them worse
so it's vitally important to find the
real underlying cause to your problem
unfortunately you don't see much of that
in medicine so today as i go through the
potential causes
try to see if one resonates with you
more than others i do know that when you
present a person with the real problem a
lot of times they just intuitively you
know it just makes sense to them it's
like yes that's it
finally someone found the real cause so
that's what i'm going to try to do today
and give you some solutions so this
video is really about trying to isolate
the the real problem okay as far as the
solution i'm going to give you some
things to focus on but there's going to
be additional information on how to
solve this and i have a lot more videos
on that but the first step is first
trying to locate
what's underneath the inflammation now
the top-selling drug in the world is an
anti-inflammatory
humera
so apparently a lot of people have
inflammation and one little side note
which is very important and something
you should know about is that
cancer goes into areas of old injury and
inflammation so by using this data i'm
going to show you to get to the root of
it you could potentially
limit to the amount of cancer that can
spread into an area and hopefully
eliminate cancer altogether because
there's a huge
link between inflammation and cancer
inflammation and heart disease
inflammation and insulin resistance and
so it's a problem but inflammation can
come from many different sources
so when you start taking
some
natural remedy let's say it's turmeric
for inflammation it doesn't work well it
could be some cause that's not fixed
with turmeric so let's go through the
different causes of inflammation okay
first one is high iron
this is not as common but especially in
men if you have too much iron because
you have a certain
disorder a lot of men develop this
problem after they're 50 years old you
can start to accumulate a lot of iron
because iron is not easily eliminated
through the body and it can create
cirrhosis in the liver and as soon as
you start consuming anything like red
meat or
iron supplements you're going to just
feel really bad so that's a good little
clue to know that you have excessive
iron but too much iron can create a lot
of inflammation because our bodies just
cannot get rid of iron now another clue
that you might have high iron is you
donate blood and you feel better wow or
if you're female you menstruate and you
feel better
that could be an indication that you
have this problem one of the remedies is
phytic acid
which happens to be something that
blocks minerals it's like a
chelating type chemical and i always
recommend to stay away from it because
it's in grains it's going to block zinc
but as a treatment for high iron it is
effective i will put a link down below
for more information on that if that
resonates with you number two this is
the big one especially the main reason
why most people are taking this drug
right here
you have an autoimmune disease and i
have quite a few videos on this topic uh
the solution is high levels of vitamin d
three
forty thousand i use consistently over a
period of time and you will feel
better from that because if you could
just stop the inflammation from an
autoimmune especially if it's like
rheumatoid arthritis you instantly start
getting rid of the all this extra damage
that's occurring and you let your body
heal
also the other remedy for that is called
tatka together with vitamin d tutt cut
is a type of bile salt a remedy that can
activate the vitamin d receptor without
giving you vitamin d so it's a very
interesting thing but the combination of
these two can greatly help
this problem there's more to it i have
videos on it i will put those links down
below
number three
fiber
so as you know the carnivore diet is
becoming very popular because
people are just they can't handle fiber
okay and i'm not even just talking about
grain fiber that's a given if you're
consuming grains with gluten i mean even
if you don't have a sensitivity to fiber
all that omega-6 fatty acid is just
going to tear up your gut and you're
going to have all sorts of inflammation
i'm talking about vegetables
and even like beans and things like that
legumes but fiber in general if someone
has gut damage already will flare up
that inflammatory process and literally
put them in a situation where they're
feel crippled and
have a lot of skin issues and
inflammation so
if you start consuming more fiber and
you feel worse well you just might want
to go carnivore for a while and see if
you feel better but this all relates to
an imbalance with your microbes in your
gut because they eat fiber if you don't
have the right microbes or enough of the
microbes and you're going to get these
reactions from this fermentation in your
gut or if it's actually higher up in the
gut in the small intestine it's just
going to
tear up your intestines so um that's
number three number four this is
very unknown but actually by very common
and i kind of identify this in practice
because
people come in with a lot of right
shoulder pains and
fibromyalgia which is dominating on the
right side right through here which is
very common
and as you pull the string to try to
find out what's underneath it
the bile ducts
usually are jammed up with
bile sludge or
the entire gallbladder is just sluggish
for various reasons
in which case all that pressure is going
to back up and cause pressure through
the plumbing up to your liver
and which is going to refer pain all the
way through here sometimes back over
through here to the rhomboid or this
muscle right here
and
you know you'll get therapy you'll get
treatment you get medication
but unless you
really understand this and fix it boy
that problem is not going away so the
remedy is tutca okay i already mentioned
that over here it's a simple remedy it
can thin the bile
okay now everything drains
and you get instant relief and yes you
need to change your diet i have videos
on that but the point is tut cut is like
a miracle treatment if you have this
problem right here
i had this problem and it creates
bloating
severe inflammation
and
i don't know of anything better than
this right here
number
five you know this is kind of a general
thing that's very common you just get a
lot of bloating a lot of digestive
bloating because you ate out a lot at
restaurants which is loaded with the
omega 6 fatty acids or you just keep
eating regular foods with a lot of
soy oil corn oil fried in
unsaturated fatty acids boy that will
just tear up your gut two there's a
great test you can see being a home test
and i'll put that link down below that
you can actually measure the
ratios of omega-3 to omega-6 fatty acids
and you would be surprised how many
people
are very heavy on the omega-6
so not just avoiding like some of the
salad dressings but just don't go out to
eat for a while and you will see a great
improvement but things like
chicken
is very high in omega 6 fatty acids you
might be better with the grass-fed grass
finish beef because that's lower and
omega 6 fatty acids all right number six
you just had
antibiotics or you have a history of
antibiotics
which creates an imbalance in your gut
and even inflammation that can lead to
scarring in your gut which will lead to
malabsorption so if you're in that
situation
you're the type that will take these
vitamins and nutrition and it's just
nothing works because
the lining on your colon is scarred and
that also occurs with a combination of
eating a lot of grains like myself
which just tears up the colon so and
then you have this altered microbiome
you may benefit from fermented foods
okay or more probiotics however if you
get worse
then you have to avoid
these prebiotics for a while and if you
have sibo which is these microbes in
your small intestine and you'll know if
you even take a probiotic if you feel
worse with the probiotic okay or with
this this fiber or fermented foods boy
that's just going to blow you more and
then you know
you're going carnivore for a while so
there's a bit of complexity
by trying to sort that out but
um if that's your problem i have a video
for that too number seven let's say you
have low back pain this is the first
place
where a low vitamin d shows up so how do
you know if this is connected
do you do an x-ray for this do you do
blood tests yes you can do that but a
real simple way is just to take 20 000
ius of vitamin d3 and wait for a few
hours if this is causing your problem
that back pain is going away so then you
know you need to take more vitamin d3
get more sun
number eight
food allergies now of course
gluten is at the top of the list but a
lot of people are consuming like dairy
they're allergic
nuts
egg there's common ones and there's
non-common ones so well this is one of
those things you can diagnose it by
rotating your eating start avoiding
certain foods see if you feel better see
if there's less bloating see if there's
less reaction to your skin so you can
kind of isolate and then get a test to
see what food allergies you really have
one way to correct an allergy both
seasonal and environmental is to do
periodic prolonged fasting that actually
will fix your immune system i have
videos on that too
okay so infection
it's number nine let's say there's a
deep uh infection in your body from an
infected tooth that you have
that um
you have no idea that's connected if you
had a lot of dental work and then also
notice
problems after that
that could be why there's a lot of
connection between
dental work as well as root canals
and then you get this systemic infection
that can affect your joints as arthritis
you can also have a latent infection
from like
an epstein-barr virus a latent infection
is something a virus that goes dormant
and then it waits there
until you're old and stressed out and
then it comes out and kicks your butt
so
that usually shows up in kind of like
lethargy chronic fatigue syndrome
fibromyalgia
and not necessarily a full-blown
infection
but the key
thing with this is
stress okay if you notice a lot of
problems that occur after some stress
event usually it's a big stress
then you're gonna have to do whatever
you can to get rid of that stress
because all the oregano oil that i
recommend for this infection will not
help you
because the stress activates cortisol
cortisol puts your immune system into a
state of paralysis
you have no immune system when you're
under stress it allows autoimmune
diseases to occur as well but
in general
i recommend a
natural antibiotic which also has
antiviral properties like oregano oil is
great for fungus yeast
candida
virus and bacteria but there's other
things you can take too like garlic
thyme
sage there's quite a few
now what about covid like the long
haulers the
this covet infection you have and now
you have this
chronic inflammatory condition
well that applies to this too but
there's some extra things i'm going to
highly recommend for this as well and i
did a whole video on it i will put that
down below one really important nutrient
to take
if you've noticed you have this problem
after covid is vitamin b1 and you need
large amounts over a period of time
i go into it in detail in another video
which i'll put down below
now if your adrenals this is number 10
if your adrenals are fatigued because
you've been through a lot of stress in
your life
you may have something called cortisol
resistance
so cortisol
just
it reacts to stress and it adapts to
body distress but if you have too much
cortisol over a period of time and then
your cortisol is kind of
inactivating so
a perfect example of that would be in
cushing's syndrome where you have high
levels of cortisol yet you have all the
symptoms of low cortisol you have all
this inflammation you have allergies you
have
skin problems
so
if you have a history of adrenal
problems with inflammation
adaptogens are really good ashwagandha
and of course vitamin d3 would be very
important
gout is another inflammatory condition
that is a high level of uric acid but
really what's happening it's your body
making a lot of uric acid and for some
reason your kidneys are not able to get
rid of this lactic acid so it's kind of
accumulating the best remedy for that
would be to increase your ph make it
more alkaline okay
and that seems to put you in a state
where you have
less gout attacks or less intensity and
the remedy for that would be baking soda
um alternating with apple cider vinegar
okay because if you take too much baking
soda or a period of time now it flips to
the other side so you want to increase
the ph and then decrease it back and
forth i will put that video down below
i already mentioned about allergies but
this is primarily
environmental allergies it's the same
thing you want to do periodic prolonged
fasting and then
insulin resistance is behind
a lot of inflammation
which then can cause belly fat which can
lead to more inflammation it could lead
to liver fat which could lead to more
inflammation
so
if you're new to my channel
you need to get on the right eating plan
anyway i covered a lot of information
now what i want you to do is just
comment down below
i'm very curious which one of these
indicates more
to you
than all the others
and a common thread through a lot of
this is vitamin d so if you haven't seen
this video on vitamin d
check it out i put it up right here